[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to a special edition
of women with balls but i katie balls
talk to today's trailblazers this
episode is brought to you by net wealth
the investment service and we'll be
talking about money through the
generations
do you talk to your children about what
they do with their money do they
understand how to save how to invest and
do they know what your plan to do if
your own savings and investments is
why is there such a taboo when it comes
to talking about money
to discuss this i'm delighted to be
joined by two exceptional female leaders
in the city of london they both have
over 20 years of experience in the
finance industry between them they have
13 children and have been outspoken
about working in the industry as a woman
with me today are charlotte ransom the
founder and ceo of net wealth and
baroness helena morrissey the chairman
of aj bell welcome both
now to start charlotte you founded net
wealth in 2015.
what's behind that
well um having spent 25 years as an
investment banker
i could certainly claim to know
something about finance but what i'd
found was that i'd been working
incredibly hard
earning well but not really spending any
time thinking about personal finance and
then in my last five years when i was a
partner at goldman sachs and running
part of the private wealth business for
them i became very interested in private
wealth management generally and i became
quite concerned about the sort of
generic discretionary wealth management
service in the uk in particular and
partly because i'm british i was quite
focused on on the uk
and it just struck me that there was no
um
there was there wasn't a way that the
financial consumer today could really
enjoy
the benefits of modern technology so
they were still consuming a very old
type of service model um and really the
kind of
eureka moment came after i retired from
goldman sachs and i was sitting at home
and i knew i didn't want to manage my
own money but i couldn't bring myself to
give it to any of these other
discretionary providers
and so it was time to start a new
business and really try to bring those
two things together traditional wealth
management with great modern technology
now we're going to be talking about the
generation gap today so how i suppose
children versus parents see this and i
just wanted growing up for you was
finance discuss much uh was that
something
i think i grew up in a very traditional
english household uh there were four
children and and my mother and father
and i think it was
really not discussed at all the one
thing i can remember is my father
getting very energized about the
discussion of endowment mortgages at the
time that they came out and he felt that
they were absolutely going to the wall
it turned out that he was right um but
so intermittent things like that
occasionally but but not as a a generic
subject that was discussed there have
you turned the tide now of your own
children
you taking work home and making them
well net wealth does creep into some of
our discussions at home
completely um
you know my podcast appearances anywhere
yeah thank you katie bond memories of it
that's why you're back
now um you've done a lot of work uh for
your career when it comes to women and
the gender pay gap and but ultimately
also the investment gap and i wonder do
you think there is an investment gap
when it comes to how women approach
investing compared to men definitely um
aj bell which actually i'm the chair
woman designate i don't take over as the
chair until the agm hopefully um
have done some research recently and
actually uh shown that women have less
than half the investment and savings of
men in this country in the uk which is
quite shocking really because the gender
pay gap is not that big it's about 13 on
average but women are setting aside only
180 pounds a month on average and men
are setting aside over 300 pounds and
then women tend not to invest it you
know they put it in cash which obviously
as we know has got very
low non-existent interest rate these
days so it is a big concern of mine
because if we don't invest as much as
men uh we won't have the same financial
well-being women tend to live longer as
well so actually we need to be investing
and saving more so i'm i'm on a mission
to try to correct that
and uh you have nine children so really
helping us with the child count for um
today's episode um are you starting to
have these conversations with them are
they interested in um thinking about
financing in like 10 15
30 years time well to varying degrees
which i think is going to be a theme of
our um discussion today um my children
age range in age from 12 to 30. and they
cover all manner of personalities when
it comes to the attitudes to money from
spendthrift to really living quite
monk-like existences and never seeming
to need any money but i do try to
introduce it into conversations i think
it's very much about though not just
imposing like this is money this is what
you need to learn and making it very dry
and academic it's about bringing it to
life
and having it as a kind of normal
conversation i couldn't agree more with
charlotte about there being a taboo
subject including within families in
many instances which is missing a trick
and this is why actually this network
report which i thought would be good
just to open up with before we move to a
wider discussion and q a of which please
do send your questions on the spectator
tv function in um generation game
financial tribes and family finance um
i find it very eye opening um you have
various tribes in there i think the
slight issue perhaps for me and probably
if my parents are watching is the ones
i'm drawn to the ones that sound the
most responsible but maybe with time um
but charlotte i wanted if you could just
give us the main takeaways from the
report
yeah i mean so you mentioned we've been
going for five and a half years now and
over that time we have a lot of people
coming to talk to us and we know that a
lot of people want to think about both
themselves moving into retirement and
and making sure that they've got enough
for themselves and then thinking about
this question of how do i then pla make
that next bit of the plan and how do i
think about wealth transfer and it's
very clear that it is a difficult
subject for many people and sometimes
it's difficult because they're not sure
how much they should be putting aside
for themselves and then it often extends
to the fact that it's not a natural
conversation they don't feel necessarily
to have with their children um so it was
something that we we decided to do a
survey of a thousand parents and a
thousand um young adult
young adults aged between 25 to 35 and
just to get a sense for sort of some of
the things that stood out um
fascinatingly less than 25 of those
young adult children had ever had an
open conversation with their parents
about their respective financial plans
and then um interestingly among the
parents only just over half are thinking
of splitting their money equally in
their wills um which is probably not
something as we as far as we can tell
their children would expect and their
spectator office was surprised when they
heard this yeah and and and then the
parents
and another interesting aspect to it is
that um three-quarters of the parents
felt that their children were pretty
much on top of their finances but their
young adult children didn't think that
at least about half of them didn't feel
as confident so what we were exploring
in it is that do you have this notion of
a sort of money personality and is there
if you like a financial tribe that you
might belong to and and i think it does
help inform us a bit about how we
connect with money and i'm not going to
go through all the financial tribes
there are seven in total but um for
example there's one that's known as the
self-sufficient saver which in fact is
the most dominant tribe that people
associated with um and that's where
people
they like budgeting they like sort of
planning out their money um it makes
them feel safe and secure when they do
it but at the same time they're always
anxious they don't have quite enough and
as a result they tend to save and not
invest and i thought one of the really
interesting things about that is if you
look at the
isa statistics for example there's
there's over 600 billion pounds in isis
in the uk and over half of that is
sitting in cash which is the point that
helena was just making and that's
fascinating because the holding period
for isis is over five years and yet over
half is sitting in cash and so to me it
was quite interesting that almost half
of those adults um actually responded
that they felt their tribe was the
self-sufficient saver and that seems to
be playing out in the sort of national
stats in a sense um another one which is
really interesting is one called the
wealth skeptic and this is where you
might be quite good at budgeting and
quite on top of your finances but
there's this notion that actually wealth
and the idea of having excess
money is an unattractive or unsettling
feeling and this is something that we do
find
quite often comes up within families
that they may have parents who are quite
well-off but they're young adult
children not necessarily all of them but
some of them might feel quite
uncomfortable about that wealth and we
might go on to talk a little bit about
some of the things we've experienced on
the back of that um and then a third one
is what we call the head in the sand
avoider and and again i think actually i
think um the financial services industry
has a lot to answer for here because
these are people who just find the whole
concept of personal finance really quite
overwhelming so they know they should do
something but they find it very hard to
engage with and we do know that in part
that's simply because the literature and
the regulation and the communication and
everything is is really made quite
difficult for people and sometimes it
does become overwhelming um but but
overall the main takeaway really from
the report and i think we know this is
that communication
within families and across generations
is absolutely key and we'll probably go
on to talk a little bit about how
perhaps you know to deal with this taboo
and to try and help you know people get
across what they need to do and just
before we dive into that um helena you
recently wrote a report with aj bell
about the gender investment gap um
looking at charles report do you see any
parallels uh there
well definitely i mean um
so all of the points that charlotte says
apply to women um more so in many cases
than men as i mentioned women tend to
have less in investments and so
obviously particularly if inflation is
rising their in their so-called
investments their savings in cash
are going to see the purchasing power
erode you're going to be able to buy
less with the existing pounds than if
you invest it properly in stocks shares
other assets and so forth so we just see
it compounded in the case of women
and i think as well you know the point
that charlotte's making about it being
taboo subject again i would say
women feel it seems even more
unsettled uncomfortable about talking
about money they talk about anything
else other than money even amongst their
friends or if the only examples i've
ever come across have really been when
people are
in straightened circumstances and feel
the absolute need to reach out to
somebody other than that particularly in
the uk
um and we've been talking about earlier
when we're waiting to come on about you
know that's so different from america
where people talking about all the time
what they earn
where they shop you know how much
discount they get
um what they are investing in um i
started my career a long long time ago
in the late 80s in new york and
everybody had all these conversations
all the time about switching their
mortgage to something that was more you
know uh attractive
and would save money and it was very
open and we need to get somewhere
towards that i don't think we should i'm
hoping we don't go all the way but we
need to start talking about it we are
still brilliant i think we can go a long
way down that road without losing what's
you know special but yeah yeah it's
fascinating that 23 figure in terms of
young adults who the number who said
they are having those open discussions
and i mean in a way helena preempted my
question which is
why is it we're so bad at it is it a
british thing where we don't think it's
a done thing or it's crass to talk about
money or is it the fact that you know
often if you are talking about money
it's because you could seem pushy so as
hannah says maybe if you are going to
bring out this when you're a bit more of
a desperate situation
i think there's a lot of different
subtleties to this um i i do think it's
quite unbritish but i like to think that
we're slowly changing that um and i
think that modern technology actually is
hugely helpful in that respect
um but i think also you know one thing
for example is to talk to your parents
about when you die that's not really a
topic for sunday lunch you know the
implication of talking about passing
money on has some aspect of you passing
on yourselves so i think it's very much
for the parents to start introducing
this idea not so much about
necessarily their wills as much as
understanding that as you go through
different periods in your life um there
will be times when it's really helpful
to start talking about concerns that you
might have and and and problems that
might arise that your parents you may be
surprised to know can help you with and
i had an interesting example just
recently was someone who was saying they
actually approached their parents to say
i know my brother needs
some money now more than i do and i
would much prefer that you're able to go
and help him i understand that it may
well mean that you don't end up
splitting your wealth equally but i i as
his sibling feel that this would be the
right thing to do so i think
in this case the parents were quite
surprised and it helped release a whole
sort of um sort of torrent of emotion
around this subject which can be so
difficult for people to to want to talk
about and after that it sort of
just opened it up as being something
that actually okay i understand now that
we're all pretty much on the same page
i think the other thing is that
if you're not on the same page and of
course there are going to be situations
where people within the family think
differently about this there is nothing
better than talking about it because the
biggest problem otherwise is you know
maybe for the person whose money it is
they may have passed on but they leave
that problem to
children and maybe grandchildren and
they leave all sorts of possibility for
the family disruption that could
actually have been sorted out had some
of this been addressed earlier on yeah
that's really interesting because um you
know the number of legal disputes over
family legacies hit a high in 2020 i
think
um so you can start to see and i just
wanted
i suppose broadly maybe um you haven't
what kind of problems do you think do
arise if you're not talking about
what money someone
is likely to receive obviously you never
quite know what's definitely going to
happen
and well there's an emotional
issue around money um whether it's
inheritance or just you know having
enough to live on and so forth i think
for all of us there's some sort of
emotional baggage that comes with you
know
our money situation
i think you know i mean it's going to
sound rather dramatic but the question
that you don't ask and obviously isn't
implied by parents not necessarily
giving equal amounts of money in their
wills or you know to their children
overall
it doesn't mean they don't love them
equally and i think people will assume
will assume sometimes oh that this you
know they'll read into the silence
um and it might not be at all clear i
thought it's fascinating charlotte in
your report where there were all the
different reasons given and when you
read through it yes only half of parents
roughly were going to give equal amounts
to their children when they die but
actually some of it was about making
things more equal at that point they
might have given a gift during their
lifetime and so forth so again i think
you could end up with um terrible
emotional upsets and people falling out
when already they're dealing with death
and you know the um the loss that comes
with that so
yeah it seems so obvious i think people
just shy away from talking about
death and
money and you put the two together and
it's you know a double whammy in terms
of actually having a conversation and i
don't think it is for every sunday lunch
it's for you know the
like my dad said to me the other day
when i was leaving visiting um his house
said you know i just need to talk to you
about you know my will and money and you
know what i'd like to do in terms of
gifts over the next few years and so
forth and he was the one that broached
it and we had already you know i didn't
i didn't want to think about it in some
ways but he was right too and yeah i
find it really interesting when you
crunch down the figures of those who are
not planning to you know share
inheritance equally they had you know
quite similar numbers saying i'm going
to leave more to my child who's the most
responsible and also something i'm
saying i'm going to leave my childhood
money to the child who's least
responsible
so any children watching or young adults
get responsible or give the impression
of being responsible quick
exactly um but i suppose one of the
things is
one of the calculations i suppose and
helena just actually is a lot of people
will be wondering whether they should be
doing gifts um you know spreading out uh
potential inheritance or going to the
end what kind of factors should someone
consider in in those scenarios
well this is actually i think a really
interesting point because
of course there is some tax efficiency
to getting your plans in place early and
i would argue there's some absolute joy
in terms of getting some of these plans
in place early and in giving while
living and seeing your children benefit
from it um so um there is this seven
year uh inheritance tax sort of window
if you like that you need to gift money
and it's only after seven years that it
falls fully outside of your state and so
it is always worth starting to think
about
the gifts that you want to make and and
making those plans and you can only do
that if you know of course how much
you're going to need yourself and like i
said at the beginning of the discussion
i think this is one of the things that
hold people back because they're anxious
about starting to gift if they haven't
really yet figured out okay within my
state how much of it do i need to hang
on to
for myself for my spouse you know
whether we may need care home fees to
pay or whatever it may be so
there's a lot to be said first of all to
make sure and it actually doesn't matter
what age you are i would say i mean if
you're in your 50s or in your 60s and
even if you're not even thinking about
retirement with yet maybe it's still 10
years away or 15 years away it's well
worth starting to just make an
assessment about okay so if it were
10 years in 10 years time that i retire
how much money do i think i would need
have i got sufficient um you know have i
got sufficient with a with the extra bit
on top and now let's think about can i
start to have these conversations with
my young adult children and start to
help them get set up with their first
flats or you know can i help them um
think about something that that maybe is
worrying them and and pay off those
student loans or whatever it might be
that's bothering them
and and i think that this concept of
starting to give while living is is
actually quite a powerful one and it
does tend to presuppose that you're
having conversations with your children
that you trust them
uh that you trust that their partners
are going to be people that you feel
confident over time um that you're
you're happy that whatever decision they
make will be one that you will stand
behind because you lose control
obviously of your money at that point um
so actually this question of control is
one of the other things that holds
people back that they're anxious that
should they start giving it and
circumstances change and the lovely girl
they thought their son was going to
marry suddenly disappears and somebody
else turns up that they're not so keen
on but that's just that's being a family
you know and and um you know as helena
was saying there's plenty of emotion
that goes with that that's nothing to do
with finance of course but i think if
you can start to get yourself organized
it's it is just a tremendous amount of
relief if nothing else to just have that
sense of okay i know where we stand and
i can now make that decision about
starting to give and i can think about
some of those subtleties that we just
covered but but i'm in a position where
these conversations can start happening
i'm going to start on some audience
questions shortly so do you keep sending
them in it is just in the spectator tv
function
um but just before we get that i wanted
one of the things i suppose might put a
parent off whether it is an immediate
gift or
telling their child how much they are
you know eventually going to get
is a worry it could demotivate them in a
way you want your child to be working
very hard to make money on their own
terms and then perhaps have a nice
surprise when they find themselves in a
better position later down the line um
helen do you think there's a way to
tackle that so
because i wonder i don't know if you
feel it as a dilemma yourself and you're
thinking about all nine
yes all nine is quite a daunting
prospect if i'm going to be equal and
you know all that but the um
so i i do think it's a question of
tailoring to the individual and this is
something we touched on briefly and you
mentioned in terms of the tribe so again
i think there are certain people who
probably would think okay hang up my
boots i don't need to try so hard and
are very perhaps um you know less
motivated uh as as human beings you know
to work hard and then there are others
that it would clearly make no difference
to and they would treat it responsibly
and so forth it does you know the clear
message coming across is okay give your
parents the strong impression that
you're very responsible with money and
it will carry on working really hard but
i think it comes back to really how you
bring up children you know because
clearly
uh even the wealthiest and we see this
often let's say billionaires saying that
they are not going to bequeath their
wealth to their children they want them
to make their own way in the world
most of us want to help our children out
and for them to have a slightly easier
path in life than we might have had so
finding your own way there and making
sure that they understand this is not
sort of a replacement for your own
achievements in life i mean that's just
part of parenting i think but there may
be one or two people that you have to
hold back a little bit and make it a
little bit secretive until they are
responsible enough to to make their
decisions within themselves
maybe something i could add to that
because i think it's um it's something
that we've seen and it's actually a
really interesting thing about
when you make a decision to give this is
when it becomes so important to know the
type of personality your child has and
the example i wanted to give is that we
actually had a father who had decided to
give each of his children a pretty
significant sum for their first house
and it turned out that all of his three
children two of them put that money
towards buying pretty lovely houses for
themselves and the third one gave it all
the way to charity
and you know it's fascinating the father
was very upset he hadn't expected it um
you know one could say well it was
laudable of of this young adult to take
that view and to think that actually
someone could do more with this than me
but one of the things that was very
striking to me was was not just the
father's surprise because it does seem
to indicate that they didn't necessarily
see the differences between how their
children might behave but the other
thing is that that young adult child
probably also didn't appreciate what the
options are to do with a significant
chunk of wealth so let's say they felt
well i can i can go and live in a flat
perfectly happy for 25 of that money
actually if they'd understood that they
could have taken the money perhaps and
put it into a charitable trust and then
have something which over time would go
to good causes but that rather than
having to chuck a massive lump sum at
something where you know you're never
quite sure that's all going to go to to
the cause that you might want but
actually let them
learn through experience about how to
give and how to live with wealth both
have a roof over their heads and do the
sort of thing that really matters to
them so this is another i think it's a
great example and a true life example of
things that happens going for you the
tribes am i correctly diagnosed that
person is a wealth skeptic yes correct
yes
um and because i just briefly want to
talk about investments and actually it
touches on a bit which is
i do you notice a generational divide or
is that too simple in terms of the type
of investments whether that is you know
a single goal
you know someone has when it comes to
money
they've made or inherit or or actually
the fact they want to do it more kind of
um
worthy invest you know environmental
factors things like that
well there's no doubt that the whole
move towards socially responsible
investing is something which is captured
to the imagination in particular i would
say of millennials so sort of people up
to the age of say
you know 35 40. um we definitely see
that that's much more prevalent in in
let's call it the younger generation
um but i think also inevitably
older people have slightly more complex
financial lives um because they are
maybe they're thinking about mortgages
they've also got school fees they might
be if they're older thinking about
retirement planning um they may be
thinking about divorce you know there's
a number of things that go on as you get
older which wouldn't necessarily be on a
typical millennial's plate in the same
in the same quantum
and this is actually where i think
technology is so very helpful in terms
of helping people i always call it get
closer to their money so in other words
have a mechanism to allow them not just
talking about money but actually
interacting with money beyond a
budgeting tool but actually to think
about investments and how they line up
with what you're trying to do so most
people at net wealth and at the sort of
if you like at the parent level
will have several different goals that
they're thinking about and investing
towards and what that means is they will
have different risk levels that they
associate with those goals that they're
trying to achieve and that actually and
for women in particular we've found that
that's hugely powerful to help them um
you know
envisage
how this money is being put to work as
opposed to it just sort of being put
into a just one pot and kind of fingers
crossed that it does what it's meant to
do
well i would just add because i think
that you mentioned about technology
being such sort of enabler i think it
also helps people just get started and
exploring about money because again we
you know our generation you know wasn't
taught anything
uh systematically anyway at school or in
the classroom in any walk of life really
whether university and so forth i think
that there is some these days in terms
of life skills that my youngest who's 12
particularly enjoys where they do talk a
little bit about budgeting and debt and
so forth but mostly a lot of the reason
why people don't get started investing
particularly women is they say they just
don't know how so having online
resources having apps you know we all
used our banking apps now aren't we so
that we look maybe not daily but very
frequently and we've got in the habit of
looking at money issues and again apps
can really help just in terms of keeping
track you can start small
you can start with 10 pounds a month you
don't have to have 10 000 pounds to get
started on investing um so if anyone's
watching who hasn't ever invested before
you know you can just take one step at a
time and get used to it and see what
happens to your money and then keep
adding overall time in the market is
much better than timing the market or
trying to yes i was going to ask her on
that just in terms of
i suppose more likely to be younger
individuals but you never quite know
it's almost encouraging for people to
take this long-term approach and i think
particularly when you are whether it's
you know late teens twenties early
thirties um
your
ten five years seems like quite a long
time to degree to put some money away
given all the things that could change
let alone
10 years 15 years i think it can seem
almost a little bit overwhelming
and i i wonder and it goes back to the
study in my 2 degree the fact that
parents tend to almost take more
positive
perception of having control younger
people and they personally do
so how do you think you can get people
to think about that when people are
really quite worried about the day to
day
so i think that even though everyone
says and it's true think of it in terms
of a three to five year horizon at a
minimum when you're investing in risky
assets like the stock market obviously
your money isn't unless you invest in
very illiquid things your money isn't
locked up you know you can access it and
again people get it sort of recklessly
cautious about this they sort of think
oh i just might need the money and so
never get into the habit of investing on
a regular basis if you start and then
you find actually you know what i'm not
missing that
10 pounds 20 pounds 50 pounds a month
and then you have a pay rise you think
well i haven't had that before let me
just add that in then suddenly you'll
look and you'll have a really
interesting you know sum of money that
you could do something like put down a
deposit for a flat or
buy something that you was otherwise um
unaffordable so i think it's i think
just getting
trying to not always see what might go
wrong and i say that being very
conscious that markets are very volatile
at the moment and there's lots of
uncertainty but there always is
so if you just get into that habit the
only regret i have in my investment life
is not starting sooner you know once it
got started i never i mean there were
things that didn't go well and so forth
but just get into the habit treat it
like physical well-being or your mental
health you know you kind of do things
every day these days we're all very
conscious of just trying to eat
reasonably healthily or you know walk
our steps you know which i failed
miserably in the cold today but yeah i
fell down the stairs
[Laughter]
yeah the stairs helped today we had to
um
i'm gonna go to lots of questions coming
in and any more do you um send them in
um try and get through as many as
possible about halfway through and so
here's one i'm
worried my child seems to spend money as
soon as it comes in is there anything i
can do to encourage better habits so
they make more of what i leave with them
which i suppose is touching on that
anxiety that you know
whether you uh leave your money equally
or not is
is it going to be used well and
charlotte what do you say to that
well so so it sounds as though this this
child falls into the big spender
category um which is actually quite
often something that you might find when
people are younger because it's also a
bit of a novelty you know you don't you
don't tend to have much money as a child
so whatever this parent is giving their
child they obviously are kind of excited
about it
and the behavior they're demonstrating
is like then finding ways to spend it i
i think it goes back to this idea of
trying to you know if we're thinking
about people listening tonight thinking
about this notion of communication and
how to get families in a
cross-generational communication going
what you want your child to understand
is what the options are of what they
could do with that money so a little bit
like helen was saying if you can help
them understand if i were to put some
aside what might i do with it what might
it do for me
um and it becomes actually much more
exciting
than you know rush out and go and spend
it straight away so i to me that's
really what i would suggest i don't
mention how young or old the child is
but i'm going to just suggest if it's a
young person a genuinely young person
like my 12 year old or so i highly
recommend getting a go henry card i'm
not on commission i just have nothing to
do with them um per se but it's a great
debit card effectively but the parents
in control so you can see what they're
spending you can pay them allowance each
week and you can quiz them you know you
say i see you spent x amount of money on
bubblology or whatever which is topical
because that happened today so then you
know they're only allowed one a week
it's a bubble tea you only had one a
week and now you've had two you know how
does this and you can actually start
talking in real
time
pretty much um
and and it's a great device you know
because the parent stays in control but
they can monitor the child's spending
habits um and i can monitor my big
spender versus my
what's the extreme caution one well
never spent no well no and she's not
wealth skeptic she's just like would
never swear to be you know so um and
it's quite interesting because i pay
them the exact same allowance and i i
show them my there's a pie chart that
comes up with their spending and what
they spend it on and so forth so if
you're a parent of a younger child get
them a go henry carter and teach them
good habits okay or if they're a
teenager or a teenager i can maybe deal
with those actually and i'm not um
age limit i don't know you need to have
a sort of parent figure to
so how much should we be offloading our
cash now to our children before we die
and they're hit with inheritance tax
which i think is a dilemma lots of
people are kind of juggling with yeah so
it goes back to something i was saying
earlier that i think um don't start
offloading your cash until you know how
much you're going to need because it
would be very awkward to start giving it
away and then suggest that it might be
given back will you even go any further
i might bring in this question which
completely touches on that i think we
can do it best of both worlds we are in
our 60s and would like to pass on some
of our money to our sons in the next few
years we want to keep enough to be
comfortable in our retirement and
provide for nursing home care should we
need it so how much do you keep because
it's almost tying in that isn't it yes
so um
we work a lot with clients on exactly
this
problem and and i say problem because it
feels like something which is maybe
quite difficult to understand because
there you are in your 60s um you may
last until you're 80 you may last till
you're 90 you might be you know one of
the lucky few that's going on past 100
and during that period inflation may go
up as we're experiencing right now um
and you know you may find that
investment returns change quite
dramatically as well so there are quite
a lot of variables and one of the things
that we talk a lot about is control the
controllables and and by that i mean
okay you can't control your longevity
you can't control inflation um you don't
know how long you're going to need the
money for but you can actually model for
all of those things and then there are
some things you can control one is be
invested which is what helen was talking
about you know be in the market don't
try to time the market
make sure that you're making use of all
your tax wrappers
and then thirdly make sure you know how
much you're paying and that you are
paying you know you are not paying
through the nose because there really
are ways to access now wealth management
in a much lower cost and
that starts to have a really material
impact on this pot of yours that you're
now thinking okay how much should that
pot be to last me through as this
questioner is asking
once you have been able to work through
that exercise and and as i said it you
know the with the help of advisors in
modern technology is actually quite a
simple
exercise to go through then you can
start to think about right great i can
now start to think about moving money on
and in this case you know they're in
their 60s it's a perfect time i'm
guessing they've probably got children
in their 30s or in their 40s so they've
got time to watch them enjoy the money
benefit from it you know buy a bigger
flat or move out to the country or
whatever it is that you know that they
would like to help their children do
um and and i think as well
you you give the tax ban that much less
to play with at the end of the day so
there's everything for families to think
about trying to start moving this
discussion along and moving the wealth
along to prevent the tax man getting
more of your estate than he should or he
could
i say he
well it's taxman
no i 100 agree with that i mean i think
that the modeling thing sounds daunting
again but if you can't do it yourself
and you and and you can really if you
have excel on your thing and you can
factor in you know what you actually
need to spend per month and you can
factor in a growth of investments you
can do quite a simple thing but just
work out how many
you know how much you need per year and
then do
without knowing how long you got you can
you know make an informed estimate um so
and then yeah the sooner you can move
anything excess out then obviously the
more likely you are to preserve it from
the taxman um now this is an interesting
one um on developing good habits um
hannah i'll come to you in this one
first um some of my children are big on
investing in stocks and shares others
aren't how do i get them started
so um you've seen their apps on your
phone yes i think i think it is about
finding something so we all learn i
think everybody has a way of learning
and being having their interest peaked
and it could be
through videos it could be through
watching a program it could be through
you know this kind of discussion uh aj
about just doing podcasts where they're
talking to women who've this is about
women investing particularly who
real-life women you know who don't
necessarily have endless wealth but
who've got started investing there are
lots of different devices now just to so
work out first of all what excites
uh the person that you're trying to
excite um don't give them a great
textbook that you know is going to send
them to sleep um and then perhaps
discuss again going back to charlotte's
point about you know make it make it
tangible show them what they could do if
you know they had some money
invested it and it grew at a certain
amount what that would turn into i think
most people don't understand compound
interest and their eyes will glaze over
this idea you know if you get a dividend
from a share you can put it back in and
it would grow and suddenly it all
becomes much bigger than you might
imagine if you just thought oh my
returns might go up five percent each my
money might go up five percent each year
so i think make it make it real
you know use a real life example um
i'm not sure what to say suggest if all
else fail if that fails but i think just
make sure that you are tailoring your
approach to that person's personality
yeah i mean a lot of younger people um
i'm gonna start on because being a
cryptocurrency is something that lots of
young people are very excited in um do
you think that there's a point in
engaging with that when you're trying to
get young people interested in the last
week and some newspapers were saying
it's like a casino and i do worry about
it myself for being very speculative but
if it gets some talking and if it gets
them thinking about actually you know i
could take some money and it could get
bigger or could get smaller then you've
got you've got a hook there and then you
want to translate that and say well
that's very risky and it might go up or
down you know x you know percent at a
time
these are the other things you could do
with your money that would just mean you
could perhaps sleep a bit easier at
night so whatever it is to get them
sort of at least interested
um to what degree i'm too sure would you
recommend
family investment companies in addition
to or instead of trusts as a way of
passing money from one generation to
another
yeah i mean they've become quite a
popular vehicle um and the reason for
that is that they're less complicated
that the
costs are lower for setting them up and
they're quite nice because as a parent
you can retain control because you have
you have to sort of golden share and you
you are the controlling party within the
family investment vehicle but your
children are shareholders of the company
as well so it's actually quite a nice
way i think and we work with lots of
families who are starting to do this
where you you start to involve your
children in this wealth transfer
discussion but as a parent you retain a
lot of control and you can then change
the level of the different shareholdings
if you like and the controller
shareholding has over time
i think the other thing that's happened
is that while they were relatively new
a while ago they have become less than
you and therefore the costs are
continuing to go down whereas for trusts
although you do have complete control
they can be very expensive to set up and
they're really quite inflexible and
there's also a sort of you know a tax
consequence that you still have to do a
sort of tax mark to market as a certain
period after the trust's existence as
well and you have to have trustees and
therefore you're bringing in third
parties and that becomes expensive as
well so i i'm actually quite a big fan
of family investment companies
um
why isn't personal finance taught at
school
so it is part of the curriculum now um
but but often again done in a slightly
dry way i think from some of the
materials that i've seen
um i think that we should push for it
and i think there should be a little bit
of a
collaboration here between the private
sector um you know firms like
charlotte's aj bell and so forth you
know contributing to that i mean i think
there have been various initiatives but
it's been a bit
you know there's a lot of schools and
there are a lot of year groups and there
are a lot you know we've had coveted or
we are having covid so i think there's
we have to get that point where we say
look this is so important as a future
life skill it seems to me that we don't
necessarily teach
all the important things um and
obviously be able to manage your money
and get into those good financial habits
looking after your well-being
even as a student i mean it really hits
young people quickly when they go up to
university or if they do that
and suddenly they have to budget or
manage the debt and you know it's it's
quite daunting if you haven't had any
experience so i think we should do more
it's in secondary schools at present
um again i think start young
get people used to it it's just another
subject at school and bring it in it's
often taught as part of maths again that
that works sort of but not if you hate
maths you know if you switch to [ __ ]
class already exactly
because also i think it's one thing
that's touching the report which is the
idea that you do is it fair
a lot of our financial habits we do
learn very young
well yes i mean emma maslin who worked
on the report with us who's known as the
money whisperer um she reported that
that is actually from the age of seven
that you start to um you know you start
to mimic your parents habits and and
start to kind of
have a have a sense for how you might
interact with money but one of the
things i was going to say which which
you know really makes me feel that we do
need to establish financial education
kind of across the the academic system
if you like is that we run something
called the young investor day a couple
of days a week uh days a year at net
wealth and that's for um
you know young adult children of clients
and they basically get a sort of full
half day of um interacting with
investing in its different forms and get
starting to understand some of the
language some of the sort of the
rationale for why you invest why markets
go up and down and then they actually
you know we do some uh simulations with
them where they're running money
themselves or they're running money on
behalf of somebody else and what i love
about it is that a we have as many
you know girls and boys or men and women
come and they come from every single
background in terms of you know what
they're studying so it's for people who
are about to go to university through to
those who've graduated but you know we
have historians and people who've done
modern languages we have physicists we
have um biologists we have psychologists
you know we it's really wonderful to see
how they engage and actually one of the
bits of feedback we get from the parents
then is my gosh they're now telling me
what i should be doing with my money
but it is this thing of sort of bringing
it alive and making them realize that
it's not as intangible as it might seem
and that it actually um
you know dare i say it can be quite fun
any of your children of the 13 you've
got i'm giving any of you advice yet on
what to do your money well i have one
teenager who is very interested in you
know following lots of companies and to
have doing shares but also in crypto and
is nagging me all the time about being
more adventurous you know so
so far on that holding
this question here saying my sons are
investing a lot of their money into
cryptocurrency but i am far too
risk-averse am i going to be missing out
in the future
i'm guessing you may say to the answers
no what do you well i mean you know
obviously crypto could you know and
obviously there are different
cryptocurrencies and so forth you know
you you might make a lot of money but
you also might lose a lot of money so
that's that's where people and obviously
what we're talking about here is i think
planning and not just sort of betting it
all on black you know this um
which i worry that where we're at and
and the maturity of crypto we're at but
charlotte might have a different view
well i i'll tell you my view on sort of
crypto and other kind of wacky things
which is
i like to talk about this thing called
the three-pot theory because i think we
all have sort of three pots that we live
by so you have your your liquid pot one
which is your you know your salary or
maybe dividends or rental income or
whatever it is and out of that pot goes
your daily outgoing so that's your sort
of current account
and then pot three is for either
illiquid things or volatile things and
so in the uk you know it's always when
you're
up to a certain age at a certain age
it's your house or your homes and then
it might be you know if i worked at
goldman sachs for 20 years and i was
paid in goldman sachs stocks so it might
be a concentrated stock position
it might be things you enjoy it could be
fine wine or classic cars or crypto and
in that pot is where you will
forgive these assets for either being
long-term and illiquid and sort of high
friction costs all for being volatile
because they you enjoy them and they
have the potential for high returns but
what i would always suggest is that
don't forget about pot 2. so if port 2
is where the bulk of your money should
be sitting in a diversified portfolio
sort of managed by you know hopefully
some experts who can produce what i call
sleep world returns so inflation plus a
bit or a bit more depending on how much
risk you've got you want to take
then do what you want in part three and
and enjoy it and if you lose you know
100 of the money you put on crypt it
doesn't actually matter and you've
learned from it but it's important to
put it in perspective it's a good way of
putting and looking at it um now i've
got some quite um spicy questions coming
in i i'm drawing this one which is why
should we leave money at all for our
children i mean you don't have to i
think that's worth pointing out
um
do you think there's an argument that
people should always um each their own
shoulder
well um i have only four children uh um
and you know i think it is actually
there's a very interesting point about
whether it is good for children to
inherit which you were touching on
before so i actually have quite a bit of
sympathy for parents who are saying hang
on a minute you know should i be giving
my children money in any material sense
um and and i i i actually think it can
be quite overwhelming and quite
off-putting for children to certainly to
have too much money too soon um but
there's no you know one of the things
that i think children might say to their
parents is you know enjoy your money i
mean don't please don't scrimp and save
and have a terrible old age because
you're giving it all to us you know so i
think you know so flipping that question
around i would say actually i imagine
that depending on what that means for
you as an individual or as a couple if
it's going to be really tough to pass
stuff on
i should think your children are
open-minded enough to think okay i get
it you know mom and dad need to have
that roof over their heads for quite
some time to come and i want them still
to be able to go and have a summer
holiday as well
i know we've been talking a bit about
getting uh younger people whereas you
know teens and others into
investing or starting to think about but
we have a question here as a 70 year old
woman where how do i go about making my
first investment
he wants to go have a go at night so i
guess not i don't care dispersions but
it might be the app is the way but it
might yeah i mean i think
obviously we need to know a little bit
about her in terms of whether she wants
advice or whether she wants to pick her
own stocks or whether she wants to you
know so i mean i'm gonna obviously
declare my interest in aj bell but you
know you can do you can do either there
we don't offer advice but we offer you
know you can do it yourself and it's
very straightforward
um if you're a beginner investor you can
go on the website there's all sorts of
resources to sort of teach you about
what you might need to know before you
start and party with one penny
um or you can get a financial advisor
which might suit if someone is sort of
taken up until now to think about it and
might want the guidance and reassurance
that would come with uh working with an
advisor and um
and and so i think it's just question of
first of all finding out enough
information
and not rushing headlong and thinking
all investment's good or all investments
bad it's just it's question of just
making sure and actually women all the
research suggests which i think is a
good thing about us actually we haven't
got a very gender balanced panel here
but anyway we should have that we have a
um
that we don't like buying anything or
investing in anything that we don't
understand and that's good news i think
so first of all work out what you
are comfortable investing in
and there are lots of resources on
various websites not just aj bells for
them
and i think just um hopping off that
there's a question which is you know if
you are going the wealth advisor route
and perhaps you know you do want to get
that um
expert advice ron go alone what's the
best way to find an experienced wealth
advisor
well i'm uh you know really quite biased
on this question
um
because
there is
i have to be careful here but there are
um websites who use that exact word and
i would argue are really not unbiased at
all so i i think you have to be
really careful um i am the ultimate
cynic that's why net wealth exists and i
have real concerns about
um
how little
financial consumers are really able to
get to the bottom of how much they're
being charged and what indeed they are
being charged for
so um i think you need to be very
careful i was recently asked by somebody
whether or not they should be taking um
any notice of um
you know influencers who are starting to
be increasingly active in
finance and you know one of the
interesting things about that is they
were inevitably being they were on the
pay of somebody who was asking them to
sort of channel inquiries towards them
so i think um
it it goes back actually to un knowing
what you're looking for and knowing what
questions to ask um
it's hard to know it can be but i think
if you know most people at some stage in
their lives do need advice i mean i i'm
actually quite a believer you don't need
it year in year out but that you do
probably need it if you're thinking
about retirement or if you've had a
divorce or um you know if your um
you know circumstances have just changed
dramatically for for whatever reason
and i i just think that there are
um a number of things you have to be
very careful about and
probably the single biggest
thing that can influence your outcome
is paying
too much what people don't understand is
paying an extra one percent every year
in fees which is typically great you're
giving yourself the rate you're paying
your advisor for their not just their
advice but you know for for managing the
assets and so on that one percent every
year which is typically the amount when
people come over to us
that they are overpaying by until they
find us
that over 10 years that will impact your
capital by 14
so
on a million pounds you are giving away
if you put it that way
thousand pounds or on a hundred thousand
pounds you're giving away fourteen
thousand it's a colossal percentage of
your own capital that you don't need to
be giving away so
it's it's really catch 22 because i
really feel for people that the right
thing is i understand why people want
advice and need advice and i think it's
important i mean our case we offer
advice
the other thing i would say though is i
think advice should be offered both
hourly as well as on an annual basis so
that if it is actually something you
want to if you like a mark to market you
should be able to just pay for whatever
it is you need and then move on
um but that would be my advice helena i
just wanted to bring you in what
questions do you think someone who
doesn't hasn't really done this before
should be asking because
i haven't invested uh
perhaps one day but i've seen the graphs
when they talk to you about investing
and say oh this is what you know risky
is but it ends very well eventually if
you just do it long enough and you're
looking at like okay but is this not
going to be my graph
yes well it usually isn't going to be
your graph i mean um
could i just add quickly on something
that charlo was talking about in terms
of how do you find an advisor first
because just and then i'll sort of try
to weave in and answer that so um
i don't know what you think about
pension-wise the government's offering
where if you are looking this might not
be the relevant point of entry for
someone asking but if you're looking to
sort of work out your pension situation
in my case several years ago even though
i worked in finance i had you know
didn't spend enough time on my own
personal finances had lots of pensions
spots scattered around and i just
thought i just have no idea what to do
about this pension wise is a government
facility and you can book an appointment
with somebody
and they to go through and give you some
pointers for the next steps and actually
in my case they gave me a
link to where i can find a financial
advisor in my area and so forth and i
contacted a few
and i agree with charlotte 100 you
needed to watch out for the fees and
actually i based my decision partly on
who was very upfront and clear about the
fees and very transparent about that
um
so i think if you start there if you if
your query is about pensions um it it
for me was a very good way of then for
some of my lockdown time uh eventually
sort of pretty drawing that all together
so the other question was no i've
forgotten i've talked too much what was
the other question um just in terms of
the right questions to ask when you're
meeting with that wealthy advisor i
think it can feel quite intimidating if
you if you're not someone who does like
a fae with no yeah
so i think the goal is that you want
someone who understands you who
understands you know what your level of
knowledge is who understands what you're
trying to achieve who understands your
whole financial picture as far as
possible and to do that they shouldn't
be just arriving with some charts saying
this is what will happen if you put some
money in this that or the other
they should be spending time getting to
know you
and building a picture and then you
should be contributing to you know what
they tell you you should be saying so i
don't understand how the stock market
works and i don't understand what a
share is and so forth a good financial
advisor should be listening and should
be talking you through some of this
don't buy things that you don't
understand or get
signed on the dotted line of things you
don't understand and and do ask um for
more information if someone just don't
be talked at or talked to you know
yeah don't be bamboozled and i think
actually again sorry to generalize but i
think often women are very wary of being
sold to you know i run a mile if someone
is trying to sell me something i want to
make the decision myself but i sometimes
need the information to help me do that
and
if you don't know what to ask
just don't rush into something too
quickly spend time getting to know
whoever you pick as your financial
advisor and i've been only got five
minutes left so i'm just going to try
and sneak in um
just one or two questions with quick
fire answers as possible which is
how do you pass money to your adult
children but make sure they are
protected if they get divorced
um so i think it's obviously about
potentially you know exes uh getting
hold of inheritance charlotte any
thoughts on that one
well i mean you know one thing is
obviously the legal route and prenups
and as i understand it they are much
more common now than they used to be
which is sort of scary um and i know for
some people that would be just an
absolute abhorrent idea but it's
something which if a divorce lawyer was
sitting here that's what they would be
saying um
you know i think in in some trusts you
can organize it in a way where
potentially there is the ability to to
you know keep a certain amount um
separate but it becomes very difficult
particularly after someone if they've
been married and or you know in a civil
partnership for a long time
and then um all my money is tied up in
assets like my house and car how do i
just decide who receives what in my
family and you have nine children so i'm
going to use it
i don't have any cars so no i'm i mean
my car situation is not going to get
anybody any [ __ ] anywhere i'm afraid um
so we have gone through you know our
eldest son got married a few years ago
and actually thought actually let's
you know help with the house and let's
take some money and hopefully we'll
survive seven years i think we're down
to four three left to do so so far so
good but we have been looking at our we
have um you know our home that we
worked out how much is worth and
therefore how much can we
um afford to give to children and
actually been thinking about because
more than when we're getting married
selling it
and starting the process and and you
know you know moving
to a smaller place
and here's just an interesting question
perhaps to end them which is you know
any thoughts on skipping generations
um yes is this something you hear much
of yes
and that is ultimately what is that
going straight to the grandkids yes and
it's actually it's it's very it's great
question in fact because um
you know what you don't want is to be
contributing to your children's
estate if you like if they already have
sufficient amounts of money and it is
then taxed on them and they will
potentially already be higher rate or
additional rate taxpayers and you can
instead pass it straight on to
grandchildren and it can be very
efficient i mean you can do it in the
form of junior isis or you can do it in
bear trusts and it's a great way to help
your children without it necessarily
touching them um and so it's something
that we see a lot of and and i think
it's you know it's a very sensible idea
and it's very in sync i think with the
reality that you know we've had some
boom times and now it's much harder i
think for young people genuinely young
people to make their way in the world
we're not all expecting our children our
children's children to be wealthier than
us so i think this is a great way of
helping to improve the intergenerational
transfer of wealth
and just
i do i love sneaking in questions
[Laughter]
because we've been talking a bit about
how women particularly um
can be a bit more cautious on this and
obviously this is the woman before's
podcast i wondered there's one question
saying which apps help women learn to
invest or it might be an app i wonder if
there's any particular tools you think
uh
factory into the fact you might be a bit
more you might want the hard sell and
things like that
so i i feel that it's a bit biased for
me to say this but you know aj bell has
just launched money matters which is a
growing sort of set of resources so i
would point you there and actually today
because it is news of the press as well
we've just announced a new app called
doddle dodl which isn't launched until
the first half of next year but is
designed for you know people who want
easy cheap investing um and
something like that i don't think that's
the only game in town but something like
that that just sort of brings you in
makes it straightforward i suppose what
i would say what our experience has been
at net wealth is is that almost 50 of
our clients are women and that's really
interesting because in the discretionary
wealth industry typically it's more like
25 women because of the skepticism and
because of their sort of lack of
interest in you know really engaging
with finance so i think you know we've
managed to bring together i was talking
about the technology and and the humans
together to make this something which is
just more appetizing for women and i'm
delighted and we need more women working
in finance okay and that might be
something to do with it
i need to thank you but just before we
do i wanted one sentence if you could
each give me your best advice for those
who watching this when it comes to what
we've been talking about you know
whether it's investing saving leaving
something or choosing not to leave
something if you don't want to but
what's your best advising when it comes
to having something to save or invest
i would say you know take the bull by
the horns and and face up to the fact
that this needs addressing you can
decide to give or not to give but don't
put your head in the sand you know take
advantage of the fact there's all sorts
of different ways as we've been
discussing today to try and get to grips
with this very important subject
sadly mine's the same it was going to be
get started you know if you did the ring
if you're not too sure about it just do
it and you know take it one step at a
time great and thank you so much for
tuning in today to this uh special
episode of women's balls i want to thank
my guests charlotte ransom and helena
morrissey and thanks to our sponsor
network for making it possible
you can watch back the session recommend
it to others on replay when the show
ends or you can catch it on the women's
balls podcast feed from the spectator so
thank you for watching and i hope you
join us again
[Music]
you